okay so the norwegian women's the beach
handball team basically the volleyball
team
for norway got fined recently because
they refused to wear the bikini bottoms
while they were playing and they wore
regular like um
board shorts instead it's the same type
of board shorts that the men's team
usually wears
but they were fined i believe 175
dollars per player who didn't wear the
175
yeah oh no it made a bunch of news
because they won
bronze in their league but they got
fined for it because they didn't want to
wear something they won bronze at the
at the olympics yeah yeah and i don't
blame them for feeling that way
why the [ __ ] shouldn't they be able to
wear shorts the way it guys do like you
make them wear bikini
they were just saying that they feel
more comfortable wearing shorts and
performing so like yeah
is there some rule though that they yeah
it's like that's their uniform oh they
wore those spandex instead
yeah i'm a fan with those and they're
actually that isn't it
i'm not even thumb but like a bikini
bottom like a swimsuit oh
is that what they have to wear let me
see that oh i know this is what they
chose
this is for the beach beach volleyball
and they got fine for it
yeah here's my thing so leading up to
this
they were cool with it but then they get
to the olympics and now they're not cool
with it
yeah why not what do you mean you say
they so they play
so that's what they played in when they
uh performed
right when they were actually competing
in the olympics in the olympics i'm
saying prior to that right they have to
wear
olympics like we're not wearing bikinis
anymore i don't know if
this was an ongoing issue following up
to the olympics and they just decided to
make that change then and there or if it
just kind of
it probably was talked about enough i
would imagine right
yeah i don't think this is a decision
that necessarily came overnight but this
is the first time that
pink pink paid their fines yeah and pink
found out about it and said i'll pay
your fines
and that's what they wanted them to see
what they that's usually what they wear
serious athletes look at these
so that's usually what they wear and
then they get the olympics and they want
to switch it
there's always that one spotter who's
shorter than everybody else huh
so bravo norwegian not bravo my thing is
this is where it gets dicey right like
you so you're playing beach volleyball
is that a handball what the [ __ ] is they
playing they call it volleyball
beach handball so beach so you're
playing beach handball
for years in this bikini
so you're playing bikini in this and
then you get the olympics and now you're
upstairs you want to swear
handball isn't that what you signed up
for
i think either way there's a movement
underway yeah
i know that's what you signed up for
yeah what it came down to is this
that's the thing when people say you
have to wear this and men can wear those
they kind of go wait a minute you're
saying i have to
no that's kind of what happens right and
it's like why
well that's because that's the girls
have to wear that uniform
and it's like i get all that my issue
with it is
you've played him i'm sure they've all
played handball since they were kids to
get to be an olympian
and then you get to olympics and then
now you have a problem let me see what
the men wear
they wear well men can't be no the men
were the speedos
can't put that dude i mean no you can't
have speed yeah
the dudes aren't wearing speedos no they
were on the uh right here
oh okay um i mean
we should allow them to wear what they
want my only thing is doing it during
the olympics
i know you mean i know oh you know i
know exactly what you're talking about
yeah
i mean by the way norway and if you look
at
statistically they couldn't be more
about equity
there are laws on the books with norway
where men and women have to represent
you know they'll essentially like you
can't have a public company without
women on the board and all that what's
really interesting about norway though
in sweden and scandinavia in general
is that when they when they enforce
these equity laws essentially because
they're
it is considered widely among social
scientists to be the most
equitable society in terms of like male
and
women roles so what's fascinating is
that
they they were like well there are so
many women nurses and no
male nurses there's so many male
engineers and no women engineers
well when you make these rules when you
when you have this really equitable
society shitty male nurses no what
happens is it's really fascinating
what happens is men go to engineering
anyway and women go to nursing anyway
so in fact there are more women nurses
than there are
and there are more male engineers
engineers because if you let people
actually make their choices when
everything's equal
what you will find this is going to
sound like a big surprise is biological
males tend to gravitate toward
certain professions that women are not
interested in sure so psychology and
things that have to do with like people
women tend to be in
nursing care men gravitate toward things
like engineering yeah dangerous more
risky stuff correct which is why
it just naturally goes there that's why
and they they work men tend to work
longer hours they tend to work riskier
hours
all those things and they tend to be
less agreeable and more competitive in
some ways
like i'm saying generally so what you'll
see is you'll see men making more money
because they're putting in more hours
the idea that in western countries like
europe the united states
there's that women don't get paid as
much that women
if they're doing the same job as men get
paid three quarters is a lie
that's not true that does not if you
look at the other factors that are
controlling that then then you can see
why
but the fact that it's due to
discrimination no longer holds water in
this society
and certainly not in europe yeah it's
interesting yeah but
it's interesting that men and women kind
of gravitate toward different things
makes sense though of course it does
of course it does